Salut Romain ça va?
Oui oui oui ! Oui oui, mais ton t-shirt là c'est euh ...
Oui je me suis dit pour changer un peu du noir, je vais mettre un tee shirt rouge qui pète bien tu vois.
Ah! Hm hm
T'aimes pas?
Hmmm ...
Vous le savez peut-être parce que j'en ai déjà parlé dans une FAQ et sur les réseaux sociaux : je suis daltonien.
Ça va, fais pas cette gueule on en meurt pas!
C'est même très vivable.
D'ailleurs le daltonisme c'est pas vraiment une maladie c'est une
dischromatopsie c'est à dire une anomalie de la perception des couleurs.
Elle doit son nom au chimiste et physicien britannique John Dalton qui l'a décrite en 1794
après s'être rendu compte que son frère et lui ne voyaient pas les mêmes couleurs que tout le monde.
Et depuis on sait comment ça marche.
Voilà.
Ah! Vous voulez savoir aussi c'est ça?
Bon. Les récepteurs chargés de la vision des couleurs ça s'appelle les cônes.
On en a entre 5 et 7 millions dans la rétine c'est à dire là tout au fond de l’œil.
Et quand les rayons lumineux arrivent jusqu'à eux ils sont excités par les différentes longueurs d'onde
qui correspondent aux différentes couleurs.
Oh mais dis donc, c'est pas du vert que je vois là-bas?
Eh! Salut toi!
Eh le p'tit rouge! Eh c'est à toi cette belle longueur d'onde là? Eh?
Oh du bleu! Oh c'est bleu! Il est bleu!
Oui les cônes c'est un peu des beaufs hein.
C'est comme ça, faut pas les juger.
Il y a trois sortes de cônes qui contiennent chacun un pigment qui réagit à une couleur spécifique.
Les S qui correspondent aux bleus,
Les M au vert et les L au rouge.
Ils sont plus ou moins excités en fonction de la lumière colorée renvoyée par l'objet qu'on regarde.
Ils transforment ça en signal électrique qu'ils envoient au cortex dans le cerveau
qui analyse les infos et détermine de quelle couleur il s'agit.
Chez les daltoniens un de ces pigments est absent ou déficient
et la vision de la couleur concernée et de toutes les nuances dans laquelle elle est présente, est plus ou moins perturbée.
Donc en fonction des cônes concernés et de l'importance de l'atteinte,
on a plusieurs formes de daltonisme.
Sans surprise, les plus fréquents ça touche le rouge et le vert.
Si c'est le pigment rouge qui est atteint, vous êtes protanope.
Et s'il est déficient, vous êtes protanormal ou protanomal.
On va garder la version sans le mot anormal, si ça vous dérange pas trop.
Si c'est le pigment vert qui est en cause, vous êtes deutéranope ou deutéranomal.
Alors ça veut pas dire que vous voyez pas du tout le rouge ou vert, ça veut dire que vous voyez pas
ou que vous voyez mal les longueurs d'onde dans lesquels sont situés la majorité de ses couleurs.
Mais comme vous le voyez sur le schéma on peut quand même s'en sortir avec les autres cônes.
Moins bien mais on peut.
Il y a aussi des cas beaucoup plus rares comme la tritanopie ou la tritanomalie
qui touche les pigments bleus des cônes.
Ou l'achromatopsie dans laquelle deux types de cônes ou les trois sont touchés.
Du coup dans ce dernier cas vous voyez tout en niveaux de gris.
En noir et blanc si vous voulez.
(musique des films des années 90)
Ça donne un petit côté vintage mais au quotidien c'est pas pratique.
Oui et bien sûr c'est pas contagieux.
Ça peut être causé par des traumatismes ou des maladies qui abîment l’œil ou le cortex,
mais dans l'immense majorité des cas, c'est héréditaire.
Le gène du daltonisme, il est situé sur le chromosome X et il est récessif.
Je vous explique. Les hommes ont un chromosome X reçu de leur mère et un chromosome Y reçu de leur père.
Alors que les femmes ont deux chromosomes X, un reçu de leur mère, un reçu de leur père.
Jusqu'ici c'est bon?
Alors, pour qu'un homme soit daltonien, il suffit qu'il reçoive l'anomalie de sa mère parce qu'il a qu'un chromosome X
alors que pour qu'une femme soit daltonienne il faut qu'elle reçoive l'anomalie de ses deux parents
parce que sinon le bon chromosome, il compense.
Donc vous entendrez souvent dire que le daltonisme est transmis par la mère à son fils.
C'est pas complètement faux mais c'est pas tout à fait vrai non plus.
D'abord parce que mon frère est pas daltonien alors que moi oui.
Donc c'est pas à tous les coups.
Ensuite parce que l'anomalie de la vision des couleurs ça touche 8 % des hommes dans le monde
mais aussi 0,5% des femmes.
Donc il y en a.
Bon mais alors comment est ce qu'on se rend compte qu'on est daltonien?
Ba souvent c'est un peu par hasard et c'est toujours un moment désagréable,
voire un peu humiliant.
Ou alors c'est chez le médecin ou à l'école quand on vous fait passer un test de la vision des couleurs
spécifique comme celui qui a été inventé en 1917 par Shinobu Ishihara.
C'est un japonais.
En gros on vous montre un cercle qui est formé d'une multitude de petites pastilles de couleurs différentes
et vous vous devez dire le chiffre que vous voyez à l'intérieur.
Suivant votre vision des couleurs est normale ou pas, vous voyez pas le même chiffre.
Et suivant le type d'anomalie que vous avez vous voyez parfois le bon chiffre
parfois le mauvais et parfois rien du tout.
Et des fois aussi vous voyez une forme qui n'est pas un chiffre, genre un éléphant.
Ça m'est arrivé, je peux vous dire que c'est un peu humiliant aussi.
Vous voyez quoi comme chiffre?
Euh ... un éléphant. Si vous avez envie d'être fixé, vous pouvez faire le test d'Ishihara hyper facilement sur internet.
Bon maintenant qu'on sait comment ça marche on va passer à la partie éducative
et il y a du boulot.
Eh! C'est quelle couleur ça?
S'il vous plaît arrêtez de faire ça!
D'abord parce que ça donne l'impression qu'on est un freak, qu'on est regardé dans sa cage à la foire et que c'est chiant.
Ensuite parce que 9 fois sur 10 vous montrez une bouteille de Coca! Et on sait tous que c'est rouge, même si on est daltonien.
Et en plus quand on a la bonne réponse on enchaîne quasiment à tous les coups sur :
Bah tu vois les couleurs t'es pas daltonien!
Oui quand on est daltonien, on voit des couleurs. C'est juste que suivant le type de daltonisme
on les voit pas toutes ou on distingue pas toutes les nuances ou on en confond certaines.
Mais des fois on a bon quand même. Donc à moins d'être achromatope complet on voit des couleurs
mais on est quand même daltonien.
Bah c'est pas dur, quand tu vois rouge tu dis que c'est vert.
Mais merci Einstein! Ah bah là tu viens de changer la vie de tous les daltoniens du monde.
T'es une génie parce que personne n'y avait jamais pensé avant dis donc.
Quand un daltonien voit une couleur
parfois il voit la bonne parce qu'elle est située dans le spectre où il a pas de problèmes
parfois il voit la mauvaise parce qu'elle est située sur le mauvais spectre.
Donc non ça marche pas comme ça. C'est pas vert égal rouge et rouge égal vert.
Déso pas déso.
Mais tu vois comment en fait?
Alors celle là c'est juste IMPOSSIBLE d'y répondre.
Un daltonien il voit comme il a toujours vu donc il a aucun élément de comparaison.
Maintenant vous le savez c'est une histoire de nuances et de spectre lumineux donc c'est indescriptible
Bon y'a bien des visuels qui proposent de montrer comment voient les différents types de daltoniens mais bon.
Ok allez je vous montre quand même.
Ça c'est la façon dont voit un œil non daltonien.
Ça c'est ce que voit deutéranomal.
Ça c'est ce que voit un deutéranope.
Ça c'est ce que voit un protanomal.
Ça c'est ce que voit un protanope.
Ça c'est ce que voit un tritanomal.
Ça c'est ce que voit un tritanope.
Et ça donc c'est ce que voit un achromatope.
Voilà comme ça tout le monde est content?
Mais bon en vrai comme on peut savoir que c'est la réalité?
Moi je peux pas vous confirmer que c'est ce que je vois.
Parce que cette image là, je la vois avec ma propre vision des couleurs qui est déjà déformée.
Et puis y'a personne qui est jamais revenu de l'autre côté du daltonisme pour dire : "ah oui c'est comme ça que je voyais oui".
D'ailleurs c'est quoi les vraies couleurs?
Vous êtes sûr vous que tout le monde voit exactement la même chose?
Si c'était si facile les couleurs on aurait pas inventé des noms à la con pour les décrire genre taupe,
caca d'oie, zinzolin. Si si ça existe zinzolin c'est du violet.
Je crois. Bon vous avez compris
être daltonien c'est des tracas au quotidien
à cause des métiers qu'on n'a pas droit de faire comme pilote de ligne par exemple.
A cause des codes couleurs qu'on nous met partout. Merci!
Et pour choisir ses slips.
Mais c'est vrai que c'est moins gênant.
Enfin pas tout le temps.
Ah alors vous avez aussi sans doute vu ces vidéos
extrêmement touchantes de daltoniens qui voient les couleurs pour la première fois grâce à des lunettes correctrices spéciales.
Eh bah il se trouve que je me suis procuré un de ces objets magiques et que je me propose de les tester pour vous dans une prochaine vidéo.
Du coup bah vous l'avez compris on va se quitter là pour aujourd'hui mais on se retrouve très très vite.
Alors d’ici là comme d'habitude,
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous bien!